you should be doing something you're
passionate about just drip with passion
find your passion what's up believe
nation it's Evan my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
an amazing gift inside you that I want
to see exploded onto the world now I
started the one rule series because I
digest a ton of content in making our
top ten series come together and the one
rule series takes some of the lessons
that come up over and over and over and
over again from the top tens and smushes
them into one video so today we're gonna
learn how you can find your passion
enjoy
[Music]
I think a lot of people look up to in
terms of a role model for achieving your
ambitions sure what is your advice for
people watching this going I want to do
that thing I love the way that you do
this how do I go about doing it what is
your golden rule I don't know if there's
a golden rule I can tell you this that I
believe anything is possible right I
live in the world a possibility and I
also believe that anything we can
accomplish anything with our two hands
and just putting in the work with our
two hands and also you hear this often
but it's really really true you got to
find something if you love what you do
and if I and be passionate about what
you do and find something that you could
be passionate like it really helps you
know it gives you that motivation when
you wake up in the morning I think you
should be doing something you're
passionate about so the question is
always you know when I give my younger
self advice you know where I still go to
Stanford lifts will go to Stanford Law
School possibly but I think a lot more
about why I was doing it was is it just
you know and I was on this super tract
and myself ended up at a big law firm in
New York you might eighth grade junior
high school year but one of my friends
wrote and I know you're gonna get into
Stanford in four years I went to
Stanford four years later went to
Stanford Law School ended up at a big
law firm in in New York we're on the
outside everybody wanted to get in on
the inside everybody wanted to get out
when I left after seven months and three
days one of the one of the people are
down the hall from me said it was you
know really reassuring to see it was
possible to escape from Alcatraz which
you know and all you do is really just
go out the front door but but so much of
our identity gets wrapped up in the
competitions we win and on that and when
you compete and I think a lot of the
credentialing resume building is this
sort of competition when you compete you
do get better at what you're competing
at if you take lots of SAT test prep
classes you'll get a better school on
the SAT and when you compete you get
better at beating people on the narrow
things you need to beat them on but but
you often it it often comes at this very
high price of of losing sight of what's
what's truly valuable and important and
meaningful which is well I think passion
there's well there's sort of all sorts
of other there all sorts of things that
that could be that but but i think i
think it often that i think it often
ends up being something that's a little
bit off the beaten path because i think
you know there's obviously financial
where you get to be have a monopoly like
business that there's a meaningful
version i think is always counterfactual
where if you weren't doing this would
you know it's great to be working on
problems where if you weren't working on
them nobody else would do them you know
if you're working at the fourth online
pet food company the tenth inform solar
panel company the one thousandth
restaurant in Philadelphia there's a
sense that if you weren't doing it
someone else would you know if you're
working at at something where it's the
only thing of its kind in the world
that's very meaningful if we weren't if
we won't end it to be for-profit
nonprofit all sorts of context if we
weren't doing this this problem would
absolutely not be tackled I think that's
the kind of that that's what's that's
what's meaningful you're not like the
regular guy who owns a team who just you
know sits on the sidelines and his
family can you be involved to the other
team oh yeah if you try to get them
assigned with you don't you decide when
I'm like Mark Cuban is all oh yeah look
you know I've been a basketball junkie
my entire life since I've been five
years old and um I just get into it you
know we all have something right where
you're just like I asked all right just
super passionate right and that it's
always been basketball for me I mean
during a game I'm out of control right
those forty eight minutes any other time
I'm like this I just feel like advice
that I would that I would give it's just
like let yourself be so consumed in in
your art or whatever your passion is
it's literally the greatest feeling in
the world it's like love like it's you
know to just let yourself be just like
swallowed whole by what makes you feel
alive and what connects you to you know
the universe and that inner voice it
there's nothing more more beautiful than
that and it's such a it's such a
selfless thing to
share that you know to share that with
the world because I think I love that
there's and there's this quote I can't
remember it word for word but this guy's
has something like share your share your
talent and share your dreams of the
world because what the world needs is
more people who come alive
something something along those lines
but yeah because you know by you just
expressing yourself
you kind of ignite you can you know
ignite a fire in somebody else sure to
express themself in some way you know
like and that was just in your said I
would just make us all like so much
happier as people you know what I mean
like just do everything do everything
for love and you'll you'll feel so
fulfilled you know when you look at
what's being done on YouTube and
everything else it's about the love and
the passion you can get away with murder
if you've got a you like a quirk or if
you're kind of single-minded in you know
there's loads of crap stuff that's
single minded and it does well because
it's single minded but I think you know
regardless of all the clever or weird
bits and pieces about things at work I
think good old-fashioned quality values
and authenticity and passion you know
just drip with passion I think you can't
you can't mess with that that's like
that's the tree call that's the real
deal and I think I think looking back
you know to be so young and so excited
about food was quite rare or seemingly
it hadn't really been expressed on
British TV before I just love music you
know and I've always had an appreciation
you know and a love for music but I
didn't know that I wanted to do music
until you know guitar hero I picked up
guitar here and I was reading on that
expert mode I had like the elbow when
you hit the thing with your elbow and I
felt super cool so I told my mom give me
a guitar and that's you know from then
that's where I really wanted to make
music and keep writing my own songs and
express myself
I made on my own B's recording on
audacity the free recording program I
did it all myself I didn't casein be
quiet I'm trying to record people in my
school know that you know I mean cuz you
know I was really just trying to do what
I wanted to do and there was all really
supportive of that so I was like you
know everybody's telling me to do this
be supportive so I just want to take it
to the next level so listen this is
probably one of the most common rules
that we get consistently across
successful people in all walks of life
athletes entrepreneurs musicians
inventors passion person passion passion
passion passion passion passion passion
passion passion passion passion passion
past and passionate passion passion
people who reach the top in whatever
they're doing consistently say that you
need to follow your passion and I think
the number one reason why people fail in
business in life is because they're not
doing the thing that they're passionate
about is because they're making too many
decisions with the head and not the
heart work for every major decision that
you make in your life the big ones you
have to make with your heart and not
your head because your head will lead
you down the wrong path
your head only understands the logical
world that currently exists where your
heart can help you create something that
does not yet exist and you have the
ability the skills the talent the
tenacity to be able to create something
that nobody else has ever done before
and you need to unless you know where to
sit inside a box that somebody else has
created for the rest of your life
because they're off creating something
new and you're just taking orders and
following rules unless that's the life
that you want then you're going to have
to create something that is unique that
is different that is you that reflects
who you are as an individual that nobody
else can do you know I'm doing my thing
nobody else can do it like me I'm
enjoying what I'm doing right you need
to find that for yourself as well and
stop listening to your head and that's
where it gets scary because you get this
idea you get all passion excited about
it and then your head kicks
says how that's never been done before
that's risky that's scary because it's
never been done before why are we gonna
be the ones to do it and then that's
where you stop yourself and that's where
me maybe your friends stop you and your
parents stop you and the people around
you stop you and then then the brakes
come off on your dreams and you stop
where what you need to do is have these
things working together where the idea
the vision the passion excitement comes
from your heart and then you use your
head to figure out how to go about doing
it instead of saying I can't do it
because it's never been done before use
your head to ask yourself how can I do
it this big crazy thing that I want to
do how can I do it and when you start
asking your head those questions it's
gonna start giving you back answers that
support your dream and so I think most
people fail in business or if you'd like
at 80 90 percent whatever the stat is of
of businesses that fail I think it's
because people just didn't do a big
reason the biggest reason is people
didn't do something that they were
actually super passionate about they
looked at a money-making opportunity
they opened up a magazine of the 100 top
opportunities to go and chase ways to
make money in 2017 you know and they
just chase those things I think people
make that same mistake in their careers
they go into the jobs that their parents
want them to do whether they go into the
safe route and then they never climb up
to where they could go you never reach
your potential
because you're not doing the thing that
you're supposed to be doing because you
listen to this and this will always hold
you back follow your passion I believe
more in having passion I think really
caring about what you do is way more
important than than having this mental
vision of this golden future that you
want to reach having vision maybe what
gets you past the problem my argument
has all often been that if you like look
at the Stars all the time you will
stumble over the pothole in the ground
because you're not looking where you're
walking following your passion follow
your dreams figure out how you can make
a contribution with your passion but I
get it not everybody can immediately
know what they're passionate about
there's so many options there's an
infinite boundless menu of possibilities
Timothy Leary talks about the vertigo of
freedom there's so much to do I don't
know parallel you're paralyzed I get it
it's overwhelming
the paralysis of choice open up Netflix
how many times have you spent browsing
for 20 minutes and then it's like I want
to watch anything okay no matter what
you choose is not gonna be the right
thing it's up so uh you have to figure
out this this passion thing from all the
possible ways in which you could invest
yourself Steven Kotler also from the
flow Genome Project wrote this article
in Forbes that I was like holy Sh he
deconstructed passion here is the
formula here's how you find your passion
if you don't know it you make a list 15
things that you're really curious about
right Elizabeth Gilbert who wrote Eat
Pray Love often talks about the pressure
of knowing your passion and she says if
you don't know your passion at least
chase curiosity because at least you
know things you're curious about and you
can make a list so Cutler goes on make a
list of 15 things are curious about so
let's say I'm curious about space I'm
curious about existentialism I'm curious
about the singularity like you make a
list and they have 15 things now what
you're gonna do is you're gonna try to
sort of create a Venn diagram and you're
gonna find out where these things
overlap where do the three to five of
those 15 things you're curious about
overlap all right because now they're
spilling into each other see anything
you're curious about is squirting
dopamine so it's already there's
neurobiology there right but if you have
multiple things that you're curious
about overlapping that's a lot of
neurobiology right follow the chemical
trail you know like we are mediated by
neuro chemistry our ecstasy's and our
sadness is all mediated by neuro
chemistry so just chase that dopamine
hit but be smart about it
you know not the slot-machine style
dopamine hit but like here's a lot of
things I'm curious about here's where
they overlap that is the way to your
passion
clear easy follow along and you get it
then he says now you know your passion
or at least the direction of it find a
need in the world that can be served by
your passion right because then it's
like you have curiosity which leads to
passion the passion that leads to
purpose oh yeah
a reason to get up in the morning eze on
betta a reason for being a reason for
moving a reason for taking action a
reason that matters a reason that makes
you matter curiosity passion purpose and
guess what you know what your flow is so
you can also bring insights from that
idea right so these are the things that
give me flow these are the things I'm
curious about these are were these
things I'm curious about overlap and
they overlap in ways that if I go this
direction I can also be in flow when
those curiosities overlap wholly and
there's a purpose that I can serve by
being in flow playing with all the
things I'm curious about and serving a
need in the world oh my god you've
figured it out that's it done go home
bye like that's the solution while
judging which factors led you to your
decisions it's about your passion I
guess one thing to get up there and
dance well I wasn't looking for the
person that was dancing well because
it's a world of dance
everybody's gonna dance well everybody
on that stage is amazing so what I was
looking for was whatever that step above
amazing is and I feel like that comes
from me being able to see the passion of
what you're doing if the piece is sad
I'm supposed to be sad after I watch you
do it if the piece is upbeat and happy
I'm supposed to want to get up and dance
too if you can't make me feel something
with what you're doing you basically
failed now I've got a special bonus clip
from Vera Wang on finding your passion
and I think you're really gonna enjoy
but before that my question of the day
is what is your passion how did you find
it I would love to hear from you please
leave it down the comments below thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever
your one word is much love I'll see soon
and enjoy the bonus clip I was
as a salesgirl at Isola Roth and in walk
France Pataca Stein
she was then the fashion director of
American Vogue I sold her a lot of
clothes she said someday when you finish
college call me and I will give you a
job at Vogue well for me safety no clap
wha
and I came on when I told my mother this
woman's gonna give me a job at Vogue and
my mother started laughing at me she
said I'm sure she says that to all the
young women and I said no I I think she
really thinks that I can come to Vogue
and work I didn't know what an editor
did I think she saw a passion and I
think she saw a desire to work I got
totally seduced and from there on in I
fell in love with it and it just became
it became my life fashion is not for the
faint of heart
not his figure skating by the way and
considering those who this to loves of
my life I would say that in order to do
both and the Supper in a way sometimes
the loneliness of that kind of
dedication and you have to really be
passionate when you love something every
day goes by in ten minutes
and for me it was all about fashion it
really was it was my way to express
myself through dressing women and
creating things and that's a very very
seductive feeling you know when you look
at the clock and your clock watcher and
it's nine o'clock and you look again
it's 9:02 and you look again it's nine
seven well when I worked at Vogue I look
at 9:02 or 802 and I'd look again it was
10:00 at night and I don't even know
where my youth are my days or my nights
when when you're 15 years but I was I
was really really very very happy there
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that that people need
passion and not one drop of my
self-worth depends on your acceptance of
me I don't ever give up I'd have to be
dead or completely incapacitated hey
believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten roses success
I have a very special secret video for
you these are the individual clips that
I have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link the description for
details